about two or three years ago I was
working in a sales job that I hated and
now I get the freedom of doing something
that I love and and I'm not saying that
there's no other areas of my life that
need to improve there are but when
you're around people that are getting
better you feel better and you start to
realize how important your circle is and
how much people influence you around you
which is why to me it's been so
incredibly hard for me to be away from
my family because you know like that's
that's who you should be like your
number one influence should be and
that's why it's so important as women
that we build families with men that
have strong values and a good moral
compass because genuinely I don't know
where I would be without my dad
um and I can't even imagine what it's
like to like not have that backbone